I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance it is more than a week now
and yet there is no reply Donald John
Trump the first ever president-elect to
begin to try to monetize the presidency
and privatize functions of the
government and to fill his cabinet with
the crew of a pirate ship Donald John
Trump the first-ever president elect to
insist an election he won was still
rigged against him Donald John Trump the
first ever president-elect who is a
classless guy's idea of real classy of
course
he delivered his first address to the
nation in a YouTube video and worse yet
there is no reply as I said two weeks
ago I don't want to be at the forefront
of the resistance but the rest of
America's commentators and almost all of
its politicians are holding back
presumably owing to oh let's give them a
chance another chance is 5,000 chance
combined with their deep-seated fears of
unemployment and unpaid mortgages so
somebody has to do this so I will do
this line by line here now the official
resistance response do president-elect
[ __ ] grabbers pedis Berg address on
YouTube we are very blessed to call this
nation our home and that's what America
is it is our home it's where we raise
our families care for our loved ones
look out for our neighbors and live out
our dreams I'm sorry look out for our
neighbors our Mexican neighbors the ones
you said are bringing drugs they're
bringing crime they're rapists our
african-american neighbors the ones you
said are living in poverty your schools
are no good you have no jobs and America
where you say we live out our dreams
America which you said last August
twenty-seventh is in a quote death
spiral that America it's my prayer that
on this Thanksgiving we begin to heal
our divisions and move forward as one
country strengthened by shared purpose
and very very common resolved divisions
you are endorsed by the KKK your
election was celebrated at a white
supremacist convention with Nazi style
salutes and shouts of Heil Trump and
that's against the quote lugan press and
you insisted for a week after week after
week that the election was rigged and
that you were under no obligation to
honor the outcome of the vote divisions
three days after you recorded that you
were calling the Democrats whose
candidate got more votes than you did
quote badly defeated and demoralized but
go on
Trump explain to me how we will begin to
heal our divisions which you personally
caused in declaring this national
holiday President Lincoln called upon
Americans to speak with one voice and
one heart that's just what we have to do
Lincoln whose words at Gettysburg still
inspire this nation 153 years after he
spoke them Gettysburg where you spoke on
October 22nd I promised that you would
sue all the women who had accused you of
sexual assault Lincoln who led this
country not into a civil war but out of
one Civil War started by the political
ancestors of the white supremacists who
helped to get you elected by the
political ancestors of your campaign
chief now your chief White House
strategist who has a history of
denigrating women blacks and Jews
one voice and one heart let me know mr.
Trump when you obtain a heart we've just
finished a long and bruising political
campaign emotions are raw intentions
just don't heal overnight that just fell
out of the sky did it after all it
wasn't you who said the incumbent
president and your opponent were the
quote founder and co-founder of Isis it
wasn't you who accused the president of
complicity in the Orlando terrorist
attack it wasn't you who accused the
father of one of your Republican rivals
of involvement in the assassination of
President John F Kennedy it wasn't you
who asked a foreign power to hack the
email accounts and computers of United
States citizens it wasn't you who
threatened to prosecute your opponent
after the election and then last Sunday
saw your last campaign manager claim you
were not prosecuting her because you
were being quote gracious oh that's
right it was you you bullied
attacked savage undercut and threatened
every week every day every hour 417
self-obsessed months and now you tell us
your victims that we must heal it
doesn't go quickly
unfortunately but we have before us the
chance now to make history together to
bring real change to Washington real
safety to our cities and real prosperity
to our communities including our inner
cities so important to me and so
important to our country
nice pointless ad-lib at the end just
they're having exaggerated exploited and
in many cases cut from whole cloth these
almost imaginary defects of safety and
prosperity you now call upon those of us
who did not swallow your timeshare pitch
man's snake oil of hate to solve these
problems to which you will obviously
give attention only in between your
efforts to personally profit by
exploiting the government of the United
States of America but to succeed we must
enlist the effort of our entire nation
the entire nation including the majority
of this nation who voted for somebody
besides you including the plurality of
this nation who voted for Hillary
Clinton and not for you all of us
including those of us you have derided
in victory as badly defeated you get
nothing from us you made this bed and
then you lit it on fire best of luck
this historic political campaign is now
over but now begins a great national
campaign to rebuild our country and to
restore the full promise of America for
all of our people you mean people like
Betsy DeVos the nominee for Secretary of
Education who doesn't believe in public
schools and had to be ordered to pay
taxes for her local school district or
people like Jeff Sessions the nominee
for attorney general who prosecuted
african-americans for voting and who
opposed not just illegal immigration but
also legal immigration and who is also a
climate change denier or people like
Michael Flynn
presumptive National Security Advisor
who claimed Islam is not a religion and
who tweeted links to a conspiracy nuts
claim that Hillary Clinton was involved
in quote sex crimes with children and
who insanely claimed in speeches as
recently as three months ago that
legislators in Florida and Texas were
trying to impose Sharia law in those
states the full promise is to be
restored to them for the rest of us to
hell with us I'm asking you to join me
in this effort it's time to restore the
bonds of trust between citizens Trump
you personally have damaged and frayed
the bonds of trust between citizens
possibly beyond repair you have
exploited that damage and Exploited the
weaker minded of our citizenry you have
questioned the rights of those here to
become citizens and those guaranteed by
the 14th amendment to be citizens of
retaining the citizenship that is
already legally theirs you have been
proved again and again a liar a fraud a
scrounger a corrupt businessman a
dishonest tradesman where there are
bonds of trust there is no Donald Trump
because when America is unified there is
nothing beyond our reach and I mean
absolutely nothing and here finally we
agree we will now see how when America
is unified by you're already
transparently corrupt and
self-aggrandizing subsuming of the
presidency as just another division of
the vast Trump Corporation we will now
see how nothing is beyond our reach and
we shall first reach for your removal
from the White House at the earliest
possible moment let us give thanks for
all that we have and let us boldly face
the exciting new frontiers that lie
ahead thank you god bless you and God
bless america that last little touch of
the divine would be less laughable Trump
if there were convincing evidence that
you had ever shown a true belief in a
god or even in an understanding of what
God or a god or just a nameless unifying
presence in the universe
is perceived to be by most of the fools
who voted for you at the 2015 family
Leadership Summit in Ames Iowa you were
asked if you liked everybody from the
faithful to the agnostic had ever asked
for God's forgiveness I'm not sure I
have you said I just go out and try to
do a better job from there I don't think
so I think if I do something wrong I
think I just try and make it right I
don't bring God into that a picture
I don't trump either stick to that stop
adding insult to larceny by suddenly
bringing empty invocations of the
Creator into this picture or get serious
about it because based on the actions of
the first three weeks of your transition
it will not be long before the only
place which you might turn for
assistance or acceptance would be to an
almighty because right now the only
honest end to an address to this nation
is God help us
and God help America resist peace